hi I'm Steve gainer from fulbright and
today we're going to play a little bit
from the beginning of Tacoma a news
story exploration game that we're going
to be releasing extraction I hear you
control yep looks good so in Tacoma you
play as a woman named Amy who is
starting her first day on the job at
this space station as the new operations
specialist everything seems pretty much
as you would expect when she first
arrives so this is our follow-up to our
last game gone home which was another
narrative exploration game about finding
objects finding story in the environment
finding things like that ticket but also
part of the fiction of the the
futuristic world of Tacoma is that we're
in this place that is suffused with
augmented reality digital overlays on
the physical world like that notice that
we just saw that's basically a notice
that by entering this facility you are
agreeing to be recorded through a are
you may also notice that we're in a zero
gravity environment so unlike in gone
home objects that you release they'll
bounce around and float according to the
rules of low gravity Phillies
see you on the other side control one of
the challenges when you're designing a
fictional piece of technology like
augmented reality as stuff like how do
you input text so that was where our
sign language solution came from control
control come in control [ __ ] hi welcome
to Tacoma I'm Evie I'll be your station
at MIT we're excited to have another
part of the AR technology is not just
that there's like text and signage and
pointers and information overlaid on the
world but they're there these recordings
of moments that happen in the crews
lives so that was the station
administrator Evie greeting Amy as sort
of a a welcome message while she's away
but as we could tell from how events
started here not everything is quite
right on takoma station so part of what
Amy's job here is to figure out where
the crews gone what's happened to them
and basically how to get the station
back online and into normal working
order if she has to go to the bathroom
the head she may head straight to the
ladies room but one of the fun things
about working on the game is doing
research to figure out how mundane
everyday things would work in space such
as these microgravity sinks that are in
the bathroom you know we did a lot of
research into yeah stuff like how would
you wash your hands or how would you use
the bathroom for instance so you know we
have these toilet stalls that are based
on
how toilets actually work on like the
International Space Station there's more
hoses and formal stay involved than were
used to on earth and grip handles and
vacuums and buttons but yeah it's it's
it's one of the differences between
working on tacoma and working on
something like gone home is they've gone
home we can just say make it look like
the bathroom in your house but you know
we're starting tacoma from a point of
like what does the bathroom even look
like in this place so this is part of
the initial kind of introduction to
exactly what state the station is in
when you arrive the Odin system which is
the the computer assistant system on the
station is not in a proper state these
autonomous cleaning bots are still doing
their jobs but the first thing that the
that Amy the protagonist of the game
needs to do she's an experienced you
know deep space technician so when she
comes online and everything here she
comes on to the station everything isn't
in the state it should be she knows okay
I need to communicate with the ship's
computer to see what's been going on but
even Odin the ship's computer is not in
the expected state when she arrives so
the first thing that that you end up
needing to do is finding out how to get
sort of the voice of the station back
into play
I'm back there we go thank you my dear
cheers Evie when I got to please
something to you so the first AR seen
that we saw was just Evie as a single
figure greeting a me and saying welcome
to your first day on the job but one of
the things that the these AR positional
recordings give us the opportunity for
is for the player to be involved in
these moments that were recorded in the
crews lives so here you can see that
like at any kind of dinner party you
might be at there are multiple
conversations going on at once so as the
player you can choose i'm going to go
over near these these characters and
listen in on what they're saying or
listen on the other characters
conversation know that you know there's
something else is happening at the same
time like at this point well here that
Clive is giving this speech to the group
but because of where we are it's
wonderful to come logos the same way two
years at the rate of the passenger count
chocula we can hear that there are these
two characters that are off to the side
kind of whispering while everybody else
is paying attention to this rousing
speech don't worry I took a picture and
so a lot of what the the environmental
storytelling and the the kind of
discovering of the narrative is about in
Tacoma is seeing these moments between
the crew and then putting together what
happened at that time with this evidence
of things like a photograph that was
taken while that scene was happening
and this is the point where gravity
really comes into play because the the
game takes place in zero gravity but amy
has these magnetic boots on that allow
her to transfer between any flat
walkable surface so once you've been
introduced to how the system works you
basically have your run of the station
and using a fully three-dimensional
understanding of the space to explore
the the territory that the station's
made up of so in here it's not just in
those kind of elevator shafts but if you
just point up at the surface the ceiling
you transferred and now the ceilings
become the floor and you can explore all
aspects of the station and make
connections that wouldn't have been
possible if this was on earth so that's
been an introduction to kind of some of
the core aspects of Tacoma that you'll
be able to play with once the full game
comes out in 2016 we're going to launch
on PC and Xbox one thanks so much for
taking a quick first look at Tacoma